bobo you're on the air how are you bobo
in florida yeah good man how you doing
howard i have to tell you i am so
relieved that you would take me out of
the wack pack you know over the years
you put me in took me out for various
things but now i quite honestly i'm
getting [ __ ] freaked out now the drop
of light flies i put you in the backpack
no no
no no no no yes you are
you begged me you said i want to be in
the whack pack and i said you know what
you are wacky you're in it no no no i
redeemed myself over the years
let me get this straight bobo and uh and
i and i i want you to think carefully
and i know thinking is a you know it's
troublesome for you
okay
over the years you have just bugged the
[ __ ] piss out of me
to put you in the wack pack you're
constantly calling me i want to be in
the work pack i want to be the one i put
you in now you're like oh the wack pack
is cursed it's a death curse you're
[ __ ] weird here's what you're going
to wait a minute number
i strip you of the name bobo your name
is steve from florida i don't want you
calling in here as bobo
ever again that's your whack pack name
and now you insult me after i go out on
a limb and make you whack pack number
two
any things of mine in your house in that
shrine i want back oh no the howard
stern shrine is over number three
you will no longer attend special events
like the birthday show or anything we
have
i don't want to see you there
i don't want you contacting me about
birthday show tickets or other specialty
shows where the whack pack is invited
number four the bobo week we're planning
is now off the table no more bobo week
what
you heard me i'm disgusted with you
i put you in and now you take yourself
out no more bulb no more bobo puppet
we're burning it today
that's right
that cameo business you got going where
it says
bobo
60
howard stern's whack pack i want that
removed you know what his name is on
instagram and twitter bobo h stern you
get rid of bobo h stern you're not h
stern and you're not bobo you want it
out you're out wait a minute you told me
all the jacket all the jacket patches
you have of stern show are to be taken
off and finally like a sex offender you
go to your neighbors and you knock on
their door and you tell them you're no
longer in the wack pack that you're no
longer bobo that you're steve wait a
minute wait a minute i wasn't saying
take me out because i don't i i don't
like the whack back it was freaking me
out because people were dying yeah well
you went out you want it out now let's
take the oath to get you the [ __ ] out of
the wack pack once and for all and never
call me
never raise your right hand
no no no no i'm not i'm not keep me in
keep me in what i'll take my raise your
right hand
no i'm not going to do it
repeat after me i
cannot
i'm not losing all that formally known
as bobo if you ever call me again with
this nonsense
i'm going to make you take the oath and
i'm going to strip you of all your
wack-pack powers
i promise i won't i probably won't
all right now go [ __ ] straighten
yourself out never call me again with
that kind of [ __ ] and we'll never
talk about this again
i gotta ask you something what the [ __ ]
is going on with the nfl players
goodbye goodbye you've discussed me and
by the way i didn't even bring this up
no more calls to mary anne if he's out
of the wack pack let me go [ __ ] that's
right
everybody's gonna die bobo and you had
the privilege to be in the whack path
shame on you that no backpack privileges
no birthday shows right
up with stupid questions you know i
really can't believe how what's going on
in this world and let me tell you like
prince harry you know they took away
property from prince harry i should take
away his house the [ __ ] man amen
amen and all his cameo privileges and
everything else he got from the show i'm
thrilled i that's the only thing i never
met cheerleading i never made the choir
i'm in the [ __ ] world did you say you
were rejected from choir yeah i was and
i tried out so what did you think when
you tried out for a choir seriously
is it she lovely
is that real
that's how you sing
what all i need is how it
it's little is it'll do the trick